Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in
for David Pakman today. Now, if you tuned in
to the program yesterday, you heard producer
Pat doing a wonderful job talking about Donald
Trump, going after Mitch McConnell, going after
Elaine Chao. And I don't want to beat a dead horse
here, but I do want to take a couple of minutes
and talk about that story one more time, because
I do believe that there's more that we need to be
looking at here. So in case you missed the story
yesterday, Donald Trump over the weekend came out.
Let me just read it. This is what he put on
through social. Why do Republican senators allow
a broken down hack politician, Mitch McConnell to
openly disparage hardworking Republican candidates
for the United States Senate? This is such an
affront to honor and to leadership. He should
spend more time and money helping them get elected
and less time helping his crazy wife and family
get rich on China. So, of course, Elaine Chao
was Donald Trump's transportation secretary.
And yes, there were plenty of, you know,
allegations against her while she was
transportation secretary that she was steering
federal money towards her family business. They
were going to investigate that. But then after she
resigned, after January 6th, the DOJ just said,
forget it, let bygones be bygones. Right. That's
terrible. And of course, it was Trump's DOJ. But
that doesn't mean the DOJ couldn't still do that.
Right. I mean, there were credible allegations.
There was evidence that suggested that she was
using her position to benefit her family business.
Kind of sounds like the thing we ought to be
investigating, right? Isn't that the kind of thing
that we want to root out of politics? But all of
that aside. It's the attack on Mitch McConnell
himself that really stuck out to me because Trump,
like everybody else in this country, looks at the
poll numbers. And right now, those poll numbers
show that not only are Democrats most likely
going to retain control of the Senate, but they're
probably going to pick up a couple of seats, too.
They could end up picking up seats in Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania and Ohio, as well as holding on
to seats that they previously thought they
may not including in the state of Georgia.
So Democrats are sitting pretty. Republicans
are running out of money. You know, thanks
to Rick Scott being a horrible manager of the
National Republican Senatorial Campaign Committee,
they're running out of money. They're
pulling ads in crucial swing states,
including Wisconsin and Pennsylvania that I
just mentioned. And so they need a fall guy.
They need somebody to blame for the fact that
Republicans in the Senate are doing very bad.
Enter Mitch McConnell, right. Donald Trump, as we
all know, has been going after Mitch McConnell for
months and months and months, just absolutely
trashing the guy earlier this year and last year,
of course, trying to get people to run for Senate
by pledging that they will not vote for Mitch
McConnell to be in a leadership position again.
He only got two people, by the way, to sign on
to that whole deal. But this is something Trump
has been laying the groundwork for for a year,
replacing Mitch McConnell. So what he is doing
right now has less to do with McConnell's wife,
has nothing to do with the investigations
that should be taking place. He is setting
McConnell up to take the fall for the fact
that Republicans put forth some bad candidates.
And the irony here, of course, is that these
candidates that are likely going to lose these
are all Trump backed candidates. Ron Johnson in
Wisconsin, the latest poll numbers show him doing
terribly right now. Well, he's also implicated
in the fake elector scheme. But don't worry.
He said this week he came out. He's like, I was
only involved in it for, quote, seconds. Okay.
Well, you were still involved by your own
admission now. So good luck with that in court.
Then you have, of course, Dr. Oz in
Pennsylvania. We all know how that's going.
Herschel Walker in Georgia, terrible campaign
with a terrible candidate, J.D. Vance,
up in Ohio, who Trump thought was going to
be the golden boy. Can't even beat Tim Ryan.
So all of Trump's people are failing. And
Mitch McConnell has been coming out recently
blaming Trump without having to name him for
basically saddling the Republican Party with
these horrible candidates. So Trump is
trying to flip the script. Of course,
blame it all on McConnell because
his leadership is just terrible.
So he can finally oust the man that he
has had this personal vendetta against
for over a year. Probably not going to work.
Probably wouldn't work out well for Republicans
anyway, even if that happened. Because as horrible
of a human being as I believe that Mitch McConnell
is. He is good at what he does. Now, what
he does is terrible, don't get me wrong.
But that guy knows how to play the game. That
guy knows how to manipulate people. He knows
how to be sneaky, conniving, backstabbing, all of
that. That's how he's gotten so far ahead in life.
So if you remove that guy from the top of your
party, you're going to suffer. Democrats are going
to do so much better. So I guess what I'm saying
is keep up the crusade, Donald, because I would
love nothing more than to see Mitch McConnell
ousted from leadership, because that's going to
create a massive void within the Republican Party
that I don't think any of you know how to fill.